en su primer día en Washington el
presidente francés Emmanuel macú se
reunió con la vicepresidenta
estadounidense kamala Harris en la sede
de la NASA hablaron de cooperación
espacial
el telescopio espacial James webb es
obviamente uno de los mejores ejemplos
de esa cooperación y de Cómo podemos
trabajar en equipo y de cómo la ciencia
que desarrollamos por nuestra parte
puede ayudar y contribuir a las misiones
conjuntas con Estados Unidos
más tarde macus se encontró con algunos
congresistas estadounidenses Con quienes
hablo de biodiversidad y de los desafíos
para enfrentar la crisis climática
destacó la necesidad de reformar el
fondo monetario internacional y el Banco
Mundial y reafirmó su voluntad de ayudar
a los países emergentes a deshacerse del
Carbón el jefe de estado francés también
asistió a una ceremonia en el cementerio
Nacional de Arlington en Virginia
finalmente fue frente a la comunidad
francesa en la embajada en Washington
que maku se expresó sobre el tema
principal de su viaje la ley de
reducción de la inflación que preocupa
mucho a Europa
hay un riesgo hoy que está ahí y que
debemos decirnos entre amigos este
riesgo es que ante los desafíos de los
que hablo Estados Unidos mide primero a
Estados Unidos pero sobre todo las
decisiones tomadas cuyos objetivos
comparto en particular la ley de
reducción de la inflación O la ley de
chips que son decisiones que
fragmentarán a occidente este jueves
Emmanuel será recibido en la casa blanca
donde se espera que discuta directamente
con el presidente Joe biden sobre temas
económicos y de la guerra en Ucrania
antes de la cena de gala especial en su
honor a la que fueron invitadas más de
200 personas